il est indispensable de redécouvrir le
produire local bonjour je m'appelle
laure darcos
je suis sénatrice de l'essonne et
conseillère départementale
comme tout le monde je me suis astreint
t1 confinement même quasiment totale
pendant plusieurs semaines ayant été en
contact avec des personnes contaminées
je suis avec mon mari qui est une
personne à risque donc je fais très
attention et mon fils c'est son sa
petite amie nous avons des journées très
chargées le avec leurs cours et et moins
avec beaucoup de visioconférence que ce
soit le département conseiller
départemental ou préfet ou au sénat tout
de suite ça a été de me dire que
j'allais essayer de restreindre mais
sortie est donc en bonne mère de famille
j'ai regardé exactement ce que j'avais
dans mon frigidaire et je me suis
astreint à ne sortir que deux fois par
semaine j'ai la chance d'avoir un
épicier à côté qui a des produits frais
et donc nous réapprenons comme j'imagine
beaucoup de français à manger vraiment
équilibré et avec de vrais pros dit et
j'en refais enfin des choses saines pour
toute la famille de prendre se recentre
un effet sur l'essentiel c'est à dire
qu'on se rend compte aujourd'hui qu'on
n'a pas besoin peut-être de certains
déplacements et qu'au fond en
s'organisant mieux on peut peut-être
rester plus facilement en fait chez soi
et moins gaspiller des voyages à bhl à
grande distance beaucoup déplacement est
en fait le télétravail me permet
aujourd'hui vraiment de je chantais déjà
quasiment convaincu que c'était un
nouveau mode de travail que nous devrons
trouver et quand on voit finalement la
pollution qui baissent depuis ses 3 300
de confinement vous rendez compte que
peut-être en effet il va falloir changer
complètement notre mode de
fonctionnement après cette crise
le vrai risque à court terme pour
l'économie de proximité c'est de ne pas
avoir les reins assez solides d'un point
de vue financier pour repartir je peux
pas me résoudre faillites d'entreprises
aux pertes d'emplois qui en seront les
conséquences directes
j'attends beaucoup des banques qui
doivent adopter un comportement vertueux
et solidaire l'état à travers lui la
sûreté nationale doivent également être
au rendez vous l'important sera d'être
prêt à relancer chaque secteur de
l'artisanat et du bâtiment dès la fin la
période du confinement
cela signifie que les démarches doivent
être construites en amont avec les
banques les fournisseurs les donneurs
d'ordre les bailleurs et bien entendu
les salariés qui ont plus que d'autres
doivent se mobiliser pleinement pour la
survie de leur entreprise et leur emploi
le parlement sera bien entendu
particulièrement actifs il faudra en
particulier s'interroger sur la mutation
de notre économie est sur la liste et de
relais aux localiser une partie de notre
appareil productif
après avoir expérimenté la
mondialisation il est indispensable de
redécouvrir le produire local et ça je
pense que tout le monde en est conscient
allez au restaurant avec des copains et
bien ce que je vais faire ce soir
c'est à dire un petit héros type
parolier et aux carottes est une recette
que m'avait inculqué ma maman j'ai lu il
ya quelques jours un livre très très
amusant et en même temps très instructif
c'est pas le vol de la joconde par frans
dan franck et qui retrace l'épopée entre
apollinaire et picasso dans les rues de
paris au début du siècle quand ils ont
été soupçonnés d'avoir volé la joconde
hors norme
parce que c'est un film exceptionnel
sur les autistes et les personnes
handicapées lourdes qui sont refusés
dans tous les établissements avec un
vincent cassel absolument exceptionnel
dans ce rôle
[Musique]